Okay.
Hey, what's going on and spill? Burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. Yeah.
[inaudible]
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on just
seeing how your week's going.
You know a lot of people when
they podcasts for one week,
they don't fucking think about their
listeners for the rest of the week,
but you know what, not this
guy, I think about you.
I think I think about you.
What was it that was
fucking guns and roses,
right? All that fucking falsetto
singing back then. Oh Lee,
you woo hoo, Hoo, Hoo, Hoo, Hoo,
hoo.
Everyone will go nuts and they would
have their fucking lighters up in the air
already. Right out of the
gate. You can say, Gee, Bill,
you have a lot more energy
than you've had lately.
What's going on with you while ty,
what's going on?
Today's the last day we're wrapping on
the movie front run of storing a Hugh
Jackman directed by Jason Reitman.
Um,
this is the last day.
I'm very excited because I think
it's going to be a great movie.
And I also get to go home and see my yeah.
Family is that my daughter over there?
MMM.
Very cool.
I got a quick little run in New York and
then I'm done and I'm just done for the
rest of the year. Other than the Times
I go to New Mexico and Arizona. Okay.
I mean, I still am a traveling
comedian. I still am a plate spinner,
but uh, I'm pretty much home til like
the end of January, which is awesome.
So I will be spending that time
with my family and uh, going in,
punching up and editing some
of the first cuts of a season,
three of f is for family. That's what I'm
doing, you know, getting into the, uh,
thanksgiving spirit.
Thanksgiving often overlooked.
Okay. You know, the second Halloween
comes along, everybody goes, oh shit,
it's the fucking Christmas season.
But people forget that there's a holiday.
You know,
the holiday, you don't have to have
any gifts. All you gotta do is show up.
You show up the Wednesday
before thanksgiving,
you go down to the local bar and a lot
of the checks that you were too afraid to
talk to are going to be down there.
A lot of the chicks that were afraid to
be talked to or going to be down there,
everybody's looking for
some sentimental sex. Right.
What are some,
what if encounters,
okay,
sorry. I don't mean to go.
All Harvey Weinstein here.
All of that was consensual.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
There's just one accusation
after another finally beat.
All these famous people are
starting to go like, yeah,
I have no idea who that is or, yeah, I
dunno. I Dunno. I don't remember that.
You know, which I was surprised right
out of the gate. They didn't do,
I'm not condoning their behavior.
I'm just saying legal advice.
Yes.
Later after the jazz has disappeared off
for you throughout the plant that you
fucking came on,
you'd think that these people would go
into denial like that fucking Supreme
Court judge. God, I, I don't know what
you're talking about. I didn't do that.
I just went back to my study and I was
reading on how to become a better person
this slowly starting to do
that. Um, but anyways, why,
why bill?
Why on such a,
a glorious holiday month would
you bring up such a scandal?
Um, there should be like, you know what,
you should start doing like a, like,
you know, you have like a
dead pool. They should do.
You should do like a pool
now where you just fucking,
you try to bend on who's the next person.
Yeah.
I can't even say anything because it's
not funny to Fuckin accuse somebody that
shit.
Um,
okay.
I'm trying to think of anybody who I've,
and I ain't going to fucking do that,
but let's get it.
Let's go with something positive.
I went to the best music store.
I've been to an [inaudible] since,
I dunno when with the best
commercial on Youtube,
which I am going to post off of the Monday
morning podcast, Twitter account, uh,
Portman's music store in Savannah,
Georgia is hands down the best
music store I've been to. Um,
what do you want? Uh, you want
a French horn? They got it.
You want a bassoon? They got it.
You want to Didgeridoo? They got it.
Are you an old man and you got to read
some charts and your fucking eyes had
gone. They actually sell readers up
at the, up at the counter a little,
you know those glasses when you don't
want to just waste your money getting a
prescription, do you just go out and you
get the readers? You just try some her, I,
these are all good things that
go right. They sold those, uh,
I went over there just to get some
drum sticks and next thing you know,
I'm actually thinking of buying a trumpet.
Okay.
I always loved the trumpet. I always love
the power of that fucking instrument,
you know?
And uh,
I actually looked at one for the first
time I had this guy explained to me the
whole way that it worked
and I was thinking about it.
And then fortunately I
called my laugh and she goes,
you're not buying a fucking trumpet.
Why do wives always do
that? They always, you know,
I'm not saying that she was wrong,
but they always do. You like,
you're not doing that. You're
not buying a boat. You can do,
you're not putting a speed bag
up on the side of the house. One.
Yeah, it doesn't rain that much
to the tree over it, honey.
We're not doing that right.
They always do that to us,
but one can,
can we always ever sit there
looking at me like, like hunting.
You're not buying another pair of shoes.
You're not buying any more throw pillows.
You already can't sit on the
fucking couch. There's too many.
I'm not yelling now.
I am.
Yes, but I, I wasn't. Oh,
you know what? Fuck you.
Yeah. Fuck you fine. I don't give a fuck.
I never didn't want to go there anyways.
Why do you hope to ruin the weekend,
right?
That's the way it goes.
Why can't we do that? What,
you know, we should just,
we've got to figure out what they do.
Obviously we can't start crying, you know?
No fucking send us to some God damn home.
I'm going to do that next time. Uh, buying
a trumpet. You're not buying a trumpet.
Dopey
me.
Tell me.
She was right in another
life, you know, come on man.
The trumpet with the plunger on the end,
getting that Jimi Hendrix. Why was sound,
maybe that's why, that's probably
where he got it from. Right?
He probably wanted to have that sound
in the guitar because he was probably
listening to somebody playing a fucking
horn. I don't know what, but uh,
I always loved the trumpet and the
trombone and the sac sex phone's kind of
hacky to like,
that's like Lichen Guitar.
Everybody likes fucking guitar. Everybody
likes somebody who comes to horns.
Everybody likes to saxophone. Write the
fucking, Trump owns the shit, right?
The trumpet,
the ability to do a big band.
And those four trumpet players
show up. They fucking, you know,
they stand up and they start
playing their little section.
They almost knock you out of your seat.
MMM.
I Dunno man. They will fucking cool.
And they were expensive as shit.
Like the cheapest one was like that they
had, there was like six, seven, 800 bucks.
You want to,
parents are always fucking freaking out
when their kid stops playing the trumpet.
It's like, dude, you know,
I could have bought a new ride Moa.
Do you know what stopped me from playing
the trumpet? Other than, uh, just poor,
you know, musical gifts was, I didn't
want to get that fucked up live.
And then the guy behind the
counter told me, he said,
all that's just poor technique.
That's just from Preston. I probably,
your amateur or whatever the fuck they
call it is wrong. So to make up for it,
you got to press it against your lips and
then you get like that, that you know,
yeah, you look like somebody beat you
with a trumpet rather than you play one.
Right? And he's like, no,
you just want to be relaxed.
You want to be relaxed since everything
is that in life, you know what I mean?
Do you want to be relaxed? You want to
hit a home run? Don't try and kill it.
Just swing through the fucking zone.
But the bat,
meet the ball there it goes right
in a little league field for me.
Professional guys, they could hit
it out of Fenway plaque, right?
Stop trying to kill it. Golf. You want to
drive it a bunch of yards there, right?
You want to show off?
You're on the first tee heavy.
All the fucking white
dude standing behind you.
One woman in somebody of color so nobody
can say you're fucking membership is
racist, right? You fly them in,
everybody's standing there watching
you. You're waiting to tee off, right?
You feel in the sweat going down the
Becky a ball bag. And what do you do?
You grip it a little tighter.
You fucking go back like John Daly is
swing outside your zone and you fucking go
through your little hat with the
pompom falls off, you fall on your ass,
you white slacks, get a grass date on
them. And where does the ball go? Huh?
Fucking record shades off the
ladies tees and everybody snickers,
everybody snickers and
you're in a bad mood.
You have a bad round and then you fucking
come home. You throw your clubs down,
right?
And then you wife comes out and once
you to emote and next thing you know you
get your hands around her throat,
right? Her eyes are rolling back.
She's making dents on the file,
what you need, you know how it is,
right?
You know how it ends.
It ends with a trip to home depot.
You buy in a pickax and some sort
of live and all you had to do,
all you had to do was just relax.
Go up this smile and wave at all
your so called friends that you know,
a rooting against you. You
know, stay within yourself,
be nice and relaxed.
Don't give a shit,
let the face meet the fucking ball there
it goes right down the goddamn fairway.
But no,
you tried to kill it and one and it ended
up happening. An innocent woman died.
Right? And how are you
going to get caught? Huh?
Cause of the back of her
head. The imprints going to
be on the hood of the car.
They come over there to dust it,
right?
And then they'll still be able to tell
it's the perfect shape of her skull with
the little blue little ponytail, you
know? And then you just sit there.
That's when you break down on the,
on the fucking stand, like all,
I'm one of those classic, uh, iron side,
the right writer with man.
Remember those old stupid court dramas,
the early days of movies
and television shit.
All the Ed to do is just ask the person,
the defendant a bunch of quick questions.
You know,
it just be like, you went golfing that
day, didn't you? Yeah. What about it?
Everyone was watching it one day.
They were watching and you squeezed the
glove clutter. I know I didn't Jabba.
And You keep saying, then you went home
and he tells you, I write it. I did it.
She never believed in my golf game.
She right.
They always did that. And then they
always shook women and slapped them.
Yeah.
You know, but that was the backbone. Oh,
Hollywood. And for some fucking reason,
67 years late, everybody's surprised
that people are running around,
grabbing people by their private,
Eh, finishing on a plant.
Um, anyways, I guess, was it the midterm
elections? I don't. What happened?
All I know is I was down on
the set and somebody said, hey,
it's a good good day for Democrats.
And I was just like,
uh, what do you mean? He goes
yesterday, man, he said the Democrats,
Democrats fucking killed it yesterday.
And my first thought was, well,
did they elect good Democrats?
You know what I mean?
I don't like how people look at politics
the way they look at their sports team.
You know what I mean?
Where like if it's a bad call,
as long as it goes into the favor of your
team, you're like, ah, that was fine.
You know, like Hillary supporters
doing that stupid. Thank you Hillary,
which was probably started by her people.
MMM,
okay.
I don't understand what
people on the left are doing.
Still trying to push her over the top.
At some point you just got to admit you
wasted a draft pick and you got to move
on to somebody else.
I've never seen somebody just keep coming
back like fucking Freddy Krueger since
probably Richard Nixon.
That has to be her spirit
animal. My favorite, my fucking,
I didn't just say favorite.
That's the thing I hate the most when
people say so and so is my spirit animal.
We fucking 11. You got
a pen pal too? Um, yeah,
like if I was her, I would just, I would
look, I would look at Richard Nixon
and be like, okay, this guy lost you.
No one on the radio last on TV.
He was sitting there, you know,
sitting there like how you normally sit,
right? He's got sweat on his upper lip.
JFK comes in all tanned up.
He's got his legs crossed,
like he's doing panel on the
fucking tonight's show. You know,
all the women are watching going off.
I had to think a political dick
that would be the deck. Right?
So everybody fucking votes, you
know, thinks that he one on TV,
Nixon loses the election and then he lost
the governor's race in California and
literally was out of politics
in that eight years later.
Oh,
tricky Dick came back and
won the fucking White House.
I think that's what
Hillary is trying to do.
MMM.
But just watching everybody on the left,
just ignoring,
completely turning a fucking blind eye
to the fact that Bernie Sanders got more
votes and the debt,
they admitted it in court.
The Democratic National Party colluded
with her campaign to make her the fucking
representative. I mean, can
you give me a fucking break?
She's fucking sitting here bitching about
the electoral college. I don't get it.
I get, if you're, you're a woman and
you want a woman to be president,
but you know, can you pick a
good one? Can we start with that?
MMM.
I mean, how much more corrupt can,
I don't know. I just don't get it.
People and being a namerd
with either the bushes and the Clintons,
I, I've had enough with them. I
want a new last name lying to me.
Is that asking too
much? Um, but so anyway,
so I checked out some of those elections
and I'm way in over my head here,
but I just saw these weird headlines like,
congratulations,
such and such state,
you elected the first transgendered
person way to go Vermont or way to go do
jersey. You elected the
first Muslim, whatever,
that this seat guy or whatever,
I don't know how to say to whatever,
there was nothing in there that you
elected somebody who was qualified that's
going to do a great fucking job.
Who happens to be Polynesian or whatever.
I don't understand it. Read the
exact same. Well that's like,
that's like how white supremacists vote.
You know,
they vote strictly by you know,
race or whatever.
Like that doesn't make any sense. Like
can we just vote for people who are good,
who actually have demonstrated that they
can not be swayed by money and they're
actually going to do what's going to be
good for the environment that's going to
be good for,
for poor people,
middle class people that's going
to be good for this country.
Don't just fucking vote for somebody
because of their genitalia or,
or you know, I mean, I
don't get, I don't get it.
This whole fucking idea that
that sociopath's selfish people.
Liars are only white male heterosexuals
and that only they are susceptible to.
Um, being weak when they get
positions of power is, is,
is not a good road to go down is the
only thing I'm going to say. You got to,
I don't know how you, uh, figure out
what the fuck somebody going to do,
but like to just be excited that somebody
got in there because of their sex or
their race is a,
is a very short sighted way to look at it.
You've got to look at what the
fuck they did is all I'm saying.
And I did not see that in the
headline. I just thought, oh good,
this person's in there,
you know?
But I feel like that's how we
try to fix shit. Like, oh my God,
there was eight years of Democrats.
Fuck this. Let's do, let's,
let's vote all Republican. Oh,
wait a minute. That doesn't work.
Let's go all Democrat.
That's what we just keep fucking doing.
And now we're going to do
that. I think on a, a, uh, a,
uh,
what do you call it?
Gender and a race thing is what they're
going to do and it's going to be
fucking, I'm telling you, you're
going to see the exact same scandals.
I did not have sex with that woman.
You wait, I want to see how this plays
out when they get in there, right?
When the non,
he's get in there and they got
their own private fucking subway,
you know everybody's eating
fucking lobster, you know,
and it's all just sitting there dangling.
You know, you want to be present.
Hey Buddy, you want to
be president, right?
And they got to get in bed with all
of these evil fucking corporations.
And then when they get in there, they
got to do what those corporations want,
right? They got to do what the fuck
they want. And then if they do,
then you end up like, like
Obama, like Bush, like Clinton,
like all of these fucking
people after their president.
Then you go on the fucking
bribe money tour going out,
air quote giving speeches, right?
Why are you still giving speeches?
You're not president anymore.
You know what I mean?
Is Dan Marino walking around with
the football still throwing passes.
He's retired. What the fuck
are you all your collect? Yeah.
Obama right now is on tour.
$69 million tour giving speeches.
Let's say the guy,
does it give a good speech
but 69 million in one year.
The Fuck Outta here. The fuck out of
here? Who's he going to go talk to? Huh?
What was he talking to, Joe
six pack? I don't think so.
Um, I know that was a very
bleak way of looking at it,
but there's something positive in there.
I think we need as,
as everybody represented,
obviously in government,
but you got to make sure
that you're not just voting,
you know,
just to get a woman in there or
somebody's got to make sure they're good.
And that is, that is my
problem with the Clintons.
I just think that they're just fucking,
they like, I don't even know what they
are. They just sold his fucking people.
There's gotta be somebody better than
her. All right. But you know, Democrats,
if you want to hang your hat around,
somebody with Mike Dukakis is fucking
charisma. Who's is comfortable in his own,
her own skin is Al Gore to fucking loses.
They can't say no to people
lost the election. Um,
have you ever heard me talk
politics as much in your life?
Would you think someone who doesn't watch
Fox News or CNN or MSNBC or anything
else who kind of just gets his news from
overhearing one comment from somebody
on a set? Well, doing
eight lines in a movie.
Um, anyways, so let's get back into my
wheelhouse. All right. What happened?
This is the podcast.
I fucking talk about what I want.
I talked about buying a trumpet
and I'm talking about a, you know,
be funny if a woman gets in into office
like, like, what is she gonna like,
how is she going to give it to,
you know,
yeah.
She gotta get like a bunch of
fucking [inaudible] like j crew,
like boy toys running around
the White House. Uh, who knows.
I don't know what they're going to do.
She'd probably go like that.
That Ferdinand Marcos chick there who
had like fucking 50,000 fucking shoes.
That's what it is. Guys are into
like, fuck it. We're animals, right?
Ladies are into stuff.
Maybe that's what it is.
They'll blow the entire defense budget
on like broaches or some shit. All right.
This is some of the dumbest
Shit I've ever said. Um,
I hope it makes you feel better
about yourself. All right. Oh,
the last day of the shoot, 84
days sober. I did it. All right.
I booked this thing. I was a fat
booze bag. I stopped fucking drinking.
I did it.
So can you and I'm so I'm a little
nervous here because now the shoot ends
tonight and uh,
so now what do I do?
It's this weird thing where I don't
want to, I don't want to end my streak.
I forget.
I get at least a hundred days,
then I've gone through Thanksgiving
without drinking. But is that a bad thing?
You know what I mean?
Rather than, you know,
drinking and kind of forgetting half the
meal and then waking up at four in the
morning with the TV still on,
you know,
sweat my ass off in some Thanksgiving
sweater being like, what the fuck?
Where is everybody? Did I
say goodnight? You know,
next day you go downstairs, you talked
to your wife, feel like a good morning.
She just looks at you and keeps brushing
your teeth. You're like, oh fuck.
MMM.
Did you have fun yesterday?
She stops brushing your teeth,
slams a hand down on the counter,
spits out the fucking turns the sink
on it, turns it off, and then turn.
So you're like, oh fuck. What
did I do? What did I say?
I don't want to do that.
I'll do that the day after,
right when I watch all
those rivalry games,
hoe did the Alabama Crimson tide
against the Auburn Tigers? Um,
I'm missing everything. I don't know
what's going on in the world. Uh,
I had a lot of people send me a
okay,
you know, tweets and t, uh,
texts and all that shit.
Unfortunately about the fatal crash.
Oh,
Bob,
sorry, I just clicked this
fucking thing off of, uh,
Roy Halladay and uh, yeah,
that's fucking brutal.
That's brutal.
Did see that guy in Boston sports
radio just fucking went off on him.
MMM.
You know,
what's hilarious about that whole clip
is he makes his point in the first like
eight seconds. He says what he feels
about it and then continues to say it.
I almost thought it was like on a loop.
He just kept going, oh, look at me.
I got to play the idea.
I'm waving at the fucking window.
He said that like nine times.
Um,
I was kind of done with the guy when
he called Halladay, uh, Jack Wagon
who says,
I understand you can't curse on the radio.
Um, I dunno, but the weird thing is
that there's, they're blaming the,
they're starting to
blame the plane and uh,
I don't think that's right. I mean,
if it's pilot error both times,
I don't think that that, you know,
what's scary is the other one. Right.
And have you thought about this the
first time that type of plane crashed?
I guess the test pilot,
he was flying into this
canyon flying low and he,
they're guessing that he thought he was
in this different part of the canyon
that was going to,
it opened up to a lake.
But this one didn't like it started
to get narrow and then he went into
basically a mountain called DSEC and if,
and basically the angle that he would've
had to fly out if he pulled back on the
stick,
he was going to fucking stall.
So he had to try to do
bang a UAE basically,
I would think. Um, yeah,
that's why I like a
helicopter cause you just go,
just stop those fucking things.
You have to keep like a shark.
They've got to keep moving forward
other than that's fucking it. Um,
but I gotta tell you, man, that plane
looks cool as hell. It really does.
It really looks cool. And um, I dunno,
but all of this shit where
people speculate and all
that, just shut the fuck up.
All right. The FAA will
investigate and like whatever.
And in a certain amount of time,
six months, a year, whatever,
they'll come out with
their official report.
All these fucking people who don't fly,
listen to them talk about,
it was kind of a, I dunno, it was
kind of funny like this and Oh,
this is the third time,
mom, blah blah. You know,
there's a lot of times if something's
easy, people will do dumb shit with it.
Like the helicopter that I
want to buy, you know, it's,
it's basically like the Robinson,
but they corrected all the safety
issues on it. First of all,
having a fully articulated main rotor
system where you could actually push the
stick forward and not enter into some
sort of low GI or mass bumping situation.
So there was a guy that got it and he
was trying to demonstrate how you could
fly like an asshole,
which is what you should never do.
And he slammed the stick forward and
he went into a nose down attitude.
But it was, it's a carborated
engine and the way the fuel is,
is fed in.
When he tipped it forward,
he basically starved the carburetor
of fuel and he stalled it,
demonstrating that he wouldn't
get into one situation.
He created another situation
and that he then crashed it.
So, you know, people
will always, I, you know,
the very little that I know about
aviation, whenever a new design comes out,
you know, people are always
like, well, let's see.
Let's let people fly in it and let them
die and then they can fix it and let you
warn you about all of this stuff.
But a lot of times it's just people,
it's just weird thing where they make
it safer and make it easier and then
someone will then do something.
I don't know,
I'll do something like that,
just slam a stick forward or something.
So I have no idea what that guy
was doing, but it's brutal, man.
So obviously condolences out to
him and his wife and kids. Man,
it's fucking brutal. Um, all right,
when with that sad frigging story,
um, that guy in Boston radio
though, it was also like,
I feel like it's much as
he felt what he was saying,
he was also trying to be edgy.
MMM.
You know,
and it's one of these things,
if anything that he was
saying was actually true,
it's like to kid don't need to say that.
Why are you adding to the pain of his
family if you really give a fuck about his
wife and kids? All right. If
somebody did something dumb,
everybody knows that they did something
dumb and then they died. Then Shit,
just shut up about it.
Let you should really upsets me.
It upsets you.
Upset you don't even know the fucking guy.
It was such like a car dash she into,
I just felt like for me that
was really upsetting. Um,
anyways. Mian ds everybody, uh,
beyond days, beyond days, don't
slam the fucking stick forward.
[inaudible] if you're in a Cabrini
fucking whatever I want to buy. Um,
why would I go into that? Why? Why the
fuck would I die? What can I say? Ah.
[inaudible] swing the club.
Nice. No single golf club.
Relaxed Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Brds
the,
yeah,
you got nothing that runs through the
legs cause I'm thinking that. Fuck it.
All right. I'm sorry. You know what?
I feel like Casey case am
I just went from a tragic,
tragic fucking story to singing
about underwear right now.
You can't make that transition. Me,
Andy's everybody. Me undies makes you,
but [inaudible] will be proud
to wear and check this out.
I'm not the only one who loves me undies.
Listen to what longtime listener
and me undies enthusiasts,
George has to say.
[inaudible] I note from George and,
uh,
Bill burr listener and be on ds Fan.
I decided to try at Mandy's BC because
I love bell bar bear. I sat it.
Okay. Is that what you
want? All right. I did it.
I tried it on this off bloody
underwear. My Dick liked it. Okay. Um,
I smile every time he sings the song.
Although it's so easy to skip
the eds and the podcasts,
I always listened to bill [inaudible]
Baba Baba Baba, you guys know this.
He loves these fucking things.
They're nice and comfortable and he loves
me on these cradling the family jewels
to get 20% off the best and softest
underwear and socks you'll ever own.
Free Shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] that's
[inaudible] dot com slash bar
. Well, that was too short.
I should probably read what
the guy said. All right.
I always listened to bill's read and
I'm so glad Mandy's has stuck with them.
It's been probably two years since I
bought my first pair of meundies and now I
have a monthly subscription because they
are that comfortable before me undies.
I used to buy the three pack of underwear
in retail stores until I realized that
I wanted to treat my junk to
something more comfortable.
And that starts with a
great pair of undies,
cradling the family jewels that is
just so slick. The way that is read,
it reeks of that.
It was rewritten by the advertisers.
I'm sure there's a George n out there,
but I don't think he wrote
it as eloquently as that.
If he did go to Madison Avenue Kid, you've
got a career, you've got a few chat.
All right. Legal Zoom,
everybody as a business owner,
you know how important it
is to keep moving forward.
But a lot of times things come up that
take your time and focus away from
growing your business.
So when it comes to reviewing contracts,
registering for trademarks are
staying current on fees and permits.
Legal zoom.com can help
simplify your life. Uh,
and they helped more than 2 million
business owners easily and affordably
navigate the legal system with confidence.
The best part,
you never have to worry
about an attorney's billable
hours piling up because
legal zoom is not a law firm.
Instead,
you get the advice you need to answer
your business questions at fixed rates
through legal zooms, nationwide
network of independent attorneys.
So take some pressure off yourself.
Go to legal zoom.com now to take care
of your business before the year winds
down.
And for special savings,
be sure to enter code burr in the
referral box at checkout. That's burpee.
You are are for special savings
only@legalzoom.com.
All right, let's continue on here. Um,
I've been so frigging busy traveling
around doing shows and finishing up this
acting gig that I have not watched.
One second of my beloved Boston
Bruins and Boston Celtics.
I haven't watched anything.
And a friend of mine on F is for family.
A Cleveland Cavaliers Fan was raving
about how well Kyrie Irving was doing with
the Celtics.
So I watched a little bit of highlights
last night of the Celtics defeating the
Lakers. I saw that Lonzo Ball, is that
his name or is that his dad's name?
I saw that he actually played well and
believe in, not even as a Celtics fan.
I'm happy for that Dude
because his fucking dad is
like such a crazy person that
it makes people hate this kid.
The kids never said Shit,
you can't pick your parents and that
the dude's dad did a lot of good things.
He is playing in the NBA,
but um,
I don't know what he's doing.
Okay.
He's fucking wrestling.
I don't know what is the one?
MMM.
I don't know what the fuck he's doing,
but that's going to be
one of those things.
To some point that kid is going to have
to make a very uncomfortable break with
his overbearing father,
but the Celtics won and I'm watching the
highlights and I don't know anybody on
the team anymore.
We still got Marcus mot.
It seems like we got rid of everybody
else. Crowder, Avery, Bradley,
Isaiah Thomas. I knew they were all
gone. But you know, Kelly, a Lennox gone.
Everybody's fucking God. There's like
two people left from last year's team.
That kid green was looking great.
What the hell did he go? I was all, I,
I missed all of these
fucking trades. So, um,
I dunno, I'm right back to only being
able to name a couple of Celtic. So, uh,
I'm excited that, uh, this, I'm
going to get back into them.
I'm going to get through my,
uh, my little New York run here.
Thank you by the way, to everybody that's
coming out to my show Sunday night.
Yeah. And, uh,
in New York City.
Thank you for getting bit in the tickets.
You can watch me trouts and material.
Fuck around,
do some shit that works and do
some shit that doesn't quite work.
And, um, but when I come back,
when I come back, I am a,
that's it. I'm watching the NBA
and NHL package and I can't,
I'm so fucking psyched of going
out on by my nieces and nephews,
a bunch of gifts. Uh, I'm going
to come back east for Christmas.
Everybody in my family who hasn't met my
beautiful, gorgeous, lovely daughter. Uh,
my wife sent me video yesterday of the
first time she was on a swing, which are,
you know, thank God for
video. I would have missed it.
MMM.
Oh it was just awesome. She was so happy.
And then the way she was sitting there,
she had like an elbow, like she was
hanging out the driver's side window.
She was so totally chill.
She has like a, like a,
like a relaxed confidence about her
and she's a sweetheart, you know?
So all I gotta do is not be
an angry maniac. You know,
who can do, I'm going to be an angry
maniac, but I'm going to be less of one.
And when she calls me out on it,
when she inevitably learns how to talk,
I'm just going to admit to, it'd be
like, you know what, you're right.
Daddy needs to work on that
because I don't want to,
I don't want to ruin what she looks like.
She's gonna be mad cause she,
I just kids going to be special. You
know, like all dads, I am a little biased,
but I'm telling you, um, anyways,
which is another reason to not be
boozing around the frigging house. Right.
Uh,
I think that's what I'm going to do.
I think in, in, in the next year,
I'll keep my drinking on the road.
That's what I'll do.
I live this double life,
stone sober at home,
pushing her on a swing, wearing
sweaters, smiling and waving.
And then on the road I'll just
be in the gutter after my shows.
That's too sad. I would
never do that. Um, anyways.
And I heard that kid for the Bruins,
that kid on bu who stepped up last year
was looking, looking very promising.
I heard he's playing really well.
I heard the Bruins of fast.
I know we don't have the greatest
record at this point, but you know,
a long season,
I cannot fucking wait to get
back to my family and just a,
you know, I don't know. I'm not
gonna do shit for like two weeks,
right through thanksgiving, right till
the end of this month. And then I'll,
you know, whatever, you'll start getting
busy again. But who gives a fuck?
I'm gonna Really gonna try to enjoy the
holidays this year. I'm getting into it.
All right, I'm going to buy a fucking
tree. I'm going to do the whole thing.
Although where I usually buy my tree,
you know,
got all of you and got all fucked
up down there now. So they prepare,
they can't sell the trees there.
Who knows what,
they'll probably knock it down the
building to put up another building.
That's the big move out
here, right? Build these, uh,
I don't know what you call him.
These high rises, luxury
rentals. Do yourself a favor.
Don't rent a luxury apartment when
you can just instead go out and buy
a starter house. Throw all that
money down the fucking toilet. Okay.
Please don't do that unless you want
it. If you want to do it, by all means,
go ahead and do it. So, um, I was
reading, I always read drum magazine,
I Read Modern Drummer magazine and um,
okay,
I saw this whole article on um,
these drummers favorite like
prog rock bands from the 70s.
And uh, you know, early genesis. You know,
when Peter Gabriel is still in it and
Phil Collins was on drums, King Crimson,
all of these bands. So I actually started
listening to King Crimson, that band,
that album red and it's
pretty fucking out there.
This shit is pretty fucking out there.
Some of it doesn't hold up,
some of it does.
But when they get into the real trippy
keyboard shit using all the effects and
everything, um, that definitely
gets a little bit nuts. But, uh,
I dunno, I was always curious
of like Bill Bruford strumming.
Like he was always on, you know,
the cover of those magazines.
I know he played in yes. And all
that time he's this amazing drummer.
So I was kind of psyched to finally be
able to hear him play. But, uh, I dunno.
I think I'm going to listen
to some of that shit.
If anybody has any good suggestions.
MMM.
I don't know.
I can't help but feel like it's very
hipstery a lot of that I don't get into
progressive. I don't mind
fusion. Fusion is cool,
but progressive gets a
little, uh, you know,
reminds me of Kevin Murphy wants
what Kevin Murphy listens to.
One F is for family, so I'll just
treat it as like research or whatever.
All right, I'm babbling here. Once again,
thanks to everyone's going to come out
to my show Sunday night and thanks to
everybody on front runner,
they gave me a part here in this movie.
I had such a great time on the
shoe and a bunch of people,
just awesome people and
okay,
I'm really excited to get back to my
family and just enjoy the holidays and
everything. This is a great
time of fucking year. You know,
it would've been nice if I could
have said that without cursing,
but I'm not the brightest guy. All
right, go fuck yourselves. Go Celtics,
go patriots. Go Bruins. I
Dunno if we have a soccer team.
I don't know what it is, but I'm
just, that's it, man. I'm going home.
I'm putting on my fucking pajamas and
I ain't doing shit for the rest of the
fucking year. Except Christmas
shopping, cooking, thanksgiving dinner,
flying back east,
meeting a bunch of relatives,
giving out gifts to the out of fucking
crisis. It's always busy, isn't it?
Who gives a shit? All right. Go fuck
yourselves. Have a great weekend.
Enjoy the music here. And uh, also,
um, we got another 30 minutes.
If you knew my podcast,
we always played like a greatest hits
from a Thursday afternoon podcast. Uh,
you know, from a few years ago. Maybe this
year. I don't fucking know. All right.
See,
you can be the best
[inaudible] [inaudible]
it's
going on. It is a bill burr and it is
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 9th, 2009. And yes,
I am a little late with this one.
It is a well into Monday evening
here in Los Angeles. And uh,
I had, I just had a whirlwind
of a week. I really did.
I really did.
It should been my,
my basically my Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
Sunday, my last whatever that is,
five days should have been filmed.
Okay with like that MTV style where
just as you start to focus on what the
images they fucking quickly cut to what
you were just looking at from the side
in a black and white,
black and white, you know,
you know your mother used
to film up punked and Ashton
Kutcher would be standing
there like, okay, check
it out. I'm fucking zippy.
Sea Crest is going to get a glazed
doughnut, right? And then Bam.
Then they go from the side and he'd
be fucking sitting there with his hat
sideways. Remember that I had like
a fucking, I had, I had an eight,
like I heard like a
totally TRL experience.
I had an unbelievable fucking week,
you know? Why do I feel like what?
I actually feel guilty about
it like telling you guys
that I had an unbelievable
week. Like I have to fucking apologize
to you guys during a free podcast.
Fuck you. You know I gotta tone it
down. Why? Because your week sucked.
Why can't you be happy for me?
Why did I turn the fucking fan on?
It's God damn hottest fucking
hell. In order to this about
my apartment? No. Bill,
what is it? Hang on a second. Let me turn
this fucking thing on. Come on, turn on.
Um, the problem is is I live in a
desert and uh, this time of year,
the sun is like three,
four hours where it just beats down
right on the corner of my apartment.
And uh,
it's just sitting there naked.
There's no avocado tree or a whatever,
cactus or any shit to block out the sun.
So it just heats up like an oven.
And then I always try to close
the windows. You know, I've,
I've explained this before because
I say Cantala in the podcast and uh,
I want my neighbors to think
I'm a swell guy. No, I don't.
I don't give a shit what they
think. I just don't, you know,
if somebody steals something,
I don't want them to think it was me.
That's basically an all right.
So this was my week.
Listen to this all you fuckers in your
cubicles, Huh? Is it Tuesday morning?
Did you already throw your hands
up and give up on me? Like,
I wasn't going to fucking do it this
week, or at least today. Shame on you.
You could have been listening to this
yesterday. At the end of your job,
you know when you're supposed
to be getting all your
spreadsheets in order, Huh?
Right around the time that egg salad
sandwiches starting to bug you and you're
thinking,
can I,
can I shoot it right into the fucking
staples office chair that I'm sitting on
that sorta has some sort
of foam underneath it? Um,
isn't that the worst?
When you have a sit down job and you
have a chair you can't fart into,
that's really bad. You know, you've got,
you've gotta wear like two pairs of
boxers every time you have Mexican. Right.
Jesus, Bill, shit jokes, three minutes.
Right. Right into the podcast. Huh?
This is how it's going to be. Sorry,
I was just adjusting myself here.
Not that kind of way.
Just to Justin everything cause I,
it's a long fucking story.
What I have to go through to turn the
fan on and keep the podcast going.
I have to stretch the technology
out. All the why is, um, all right,
this was my week. Alright, Wednesday,
Wednesday I fly to a JFK
in New York City and um,
cause I'm getting ready
for my big town hall show,
my First Theater Gig in New York City,
right?
So I'm on my way there and I land right
around five 30 just in time for the
fucking traffic.
And low and behold,
the Yankees are playing game six of
the fucking world series. All right.
And if they win that night,
they're gonna wrap the shit up.
I'm staying in a hotel in Times
Square. I bring my girl along, right?
It's a big fucking weak for me, you know,
and I'm sitting there riding and going,
please let the Phillies win. Please
let the fucking Phillies win, you know,
and then when games seven so I can walk,
watch all those fucking sad sack Yankee
fans with those satin Yankee jackets
that they wear.
You know,
like they're in some biker gang
on fucking happy days. I don't,
they're like one of the only teams left.
It's still has those satin jackets.
Um, anyways, but it was
not to be right. Then. Um,
I started to watch games,
sex and Pedro's on the mound and he
starts off with like an 84 mile an hour
fastball and I just really had a bad
feeling that I was going to watch the end
of his career that night and he was
going to let up like 17 runs and I,
I couldn't watch it, so
I shut it off. So, uh,
I have to do opie and Anthony in
the morning. So I take my vitamins,
I go to sleep or whatever, uh,
try not to get sick on the road.
And right around right around writers,
I'm starting to nod off.
I hear the first screaming that I
would hear for the next three hours.
I just hear like way off,
you know,
basically where I'm sitting in Times
Square is about a half a block away.
So all I hear right is about rate and
not off and get a nice eight hours sleep
right before I go to do the morning radio.
All of a sudden I just hear like
[inaudible] well, good stories. Yeah.
Woo.
Right. Couldn't really make
it out. It wasn't that clear.
And then I started hearing from
her, I'm sorry, these horns blowing.
And it was like the whole fucking stadium.
I guess they want it.
I figured it out at that point. That's
like the whole fucking stadium decided,
what do we do now?
Let's go to time square and keep bill
up for the next fucking three hours.
And that's what they did. And it
was so loud. It's so ridiculous.
I was actually sitting there
with my head in between two pillows,
like I was having a fucking like,
like a head sandwich. Right? It was
so fucking loud and so ridiculous.
I was actually laying there laughing.
Um, and one of the fucking odds, right?
One of the, one of the, one
of the biggest red sox fans,
one of the guys who hates the Yankees
the most, okay, I live 3000 miles away.
What are the fucking odds?
This one random day I'm going to fly
in and they're going to win the world
series and that is going to decide to
celebrate half a fucking block away.
So, uh, that was my first night. Um,
and the next night I did a Gig for a,
actually I didn't height this gig because
I was trying to sell tickets for my
town hall Gig. And, um,
I actually on Thursday I opened for this
up and coming comedian then I'm sure
all you guys [inaudible] you're going
to know about soon a guy by the name of
Dane Cook. I don't know if you've
ever heard of him. Just uh, you know,
up and coming guy, you know,
just, just trying to plug away,
I opened up for them at Madison Square
Garden, I a 10 minutes and it was,
wasn't like the, the, the
theater at Madison Square Garden.
It was where the next play.
And uh,
I'm trying to think the last time
I worked with him on the road,
I think maybe we did a college
gig together about 15 years ago,
way back when we were starting out in
Boston. So it was, uh, I gotta tell Ya,
that's, it's been a long time
since I did a gig that wasn't like,
if I do Letterman,
I get butterflies.
But it's been a long time since I've done
a standup gig where I got that wasn't
going to be on TV and I
actually got butterflies. I, uh,
I was standing back there waiting to
go on and I was like legitimately,
uh, not like nervous to the point that
there was going to fuck with my set,
but I was like,
I don't know what it was.
I stumped because I kind of got to this
like Madison, it's canyon, right? And uh,
fortunately I had the presence of
mind to be like, you know what?
When are you ever gonna get to do this
again, bill? I'm going to go with never,
I'm going to bet I'm going to pet the
long shot on this one and guests that
you're never going to get to do this
again. So, uh, or most likely, you know,
never say never. So why don't you
go up there and fucking enjoy it.
And right before Dan does
is shows in the round.
So it's like 20,000 fucking people.
And I'm sitting there looking at the stage
and I'm trying to figure out who am I
going to look at. So fortunately
before I went out there, I go, Dan,
exactly how does this theater in the
round work it? He goes, it's no big deal.
He goes, it's just like, it's like four
theaters. There's one in front of you,
one of the right one or the left and one
behind. You just break it up like that.
Then all of a sudden it didn't, it, it
just made sense. And I went out there,
he actually had a great car.
I mean, I was freaking out.
I knew I was gonna be doing the Gig for
about six days and I was just going on,
my God, is this going to be
a bunch of Facebook hotties?
And I'm going to go up there saying con
to every other word and that it just can
be looking at me like Wednesday
and coming on. This guy is angry,
but they weren't. They were fucking
awesome. And they totally listened. And,
uh, I was probably, uh,
one of the best 10 minutes sets I
think I've ever had as far as, uh,
many times you get to do a 10 minutes
set and you get to look up at a Stanley
Cup champion banner. You know, by the way,
why is Madison Square Garden? Um,
I'm not trying to be a dick here.
Why is it considered a basketball Mecca?
They always say that like when Michael
Jordan would go there, it's, you know,
it's a basketball Mecca. Lebron James.
It's, it's a basketball and they,
we say that to basketball Mecca.
All right.
Now fans of the New York Knicks.
And you're a true fan right now if
you're still watching those bumps. Okay.
Going through a real rough patch.
Um, I wanna I want you to justify,
send me an email and tell me,
explain to me how Madison Square Garden
is considered a basketball Mecca.
How,
okay.
The Knicks haven't a
championship since 1972.
I think they won the other
one in like 69 or 70.
They've won two championships.
The fucking spurs have won like what?
Four,
five.
How is Madison Square Garden a
basketball Mecca if that's a mecca.
What was the old Boston Garden?
We want 16 there or say like the La Forum,
the La Forum, they won a five, six,
seven. I don't know what they want their,
they want a good, they weren't like nine.
I think they won nine out
there. Okay. If, if if
Madison Square Garden, I'm not
gonna, I'm not being a dick here.
New York City is a
basketball Mecca that uh,
Rutger park or whatever the
fuck it is with a goat. Right.
He used to fucking,
uh,
lift up a refrigerator and put it on
top of the back board is not how the,
the urban myth goes or whatever the
fuck it was. Lew Alcindor. Right.
All those guys came from
there. I understand that. I
understand all those players,
but there's only been fun.
There's two championship banners
hanging in Madison Square Garden. Okay.
So I'm going to kind of be a jerk here
and say that it's not a basketball Mecca.
I don't think you've earned the
right, what? College basketball maybe,
you know, I dunno. I think he'll let you,
I think you guys really need to win a
lot more. The fucking Chicago Bulls.
When six in the 90s
it's the first three at old Chicago
Stadium and then the other three.
What at the United Center? Is that how
it went? I don't, I don't fucking know.
All I'm saying is, uh, you guys need to
bring that down a little bit. You know,
that's like you ever see like when
you see a restaurant they, they will,
they'll say a welcome to
two world famous blah blah,
blahs and you sitting there
really, really, they, they
know about this in Portugal.
They don't, you just say in
that, and I think that fucking,
you know what Madison Square Garden is
just like Ray's famous pizza in New York
City. Every fucking one claims
to be, there's a couple of,
there's a couple of comedy clubs.
The Ward,
the world famous fucking Yuk, Yuk, slap
a knee, whatever the fuck they call them.
It's like, it's not world
famous. It's not alright.
It isn't okay. Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah. I beat that to death.
I really got off the rails here.
Let me get back to my fucking story here.
All right.
Um,
so the first night I go Yankees won the
world series and their fans keep me up,
um, for like three hours.
All right. And uh, oh,
I actually congratulated the Yankees
on, uh, on the radio the next day,
which is probably very surprising to a
lot of people if you'd like to hear it.
Go to the wire, just Google bill burr
opie and Anthony show a Yankee rant.
For some reason they called it a rant,
but I was actually congratulating them
and I meant everything that I said and it
might've sounded like I was being
a little sarcastic, but I wasn't.
Anyways,
let me plow ahead.
So the next night I opened for Dane
at Madison Square Garden, right.
I'm fucking is pictures of
like Frank Sinatra and Elvis,
I'm talking to the security guard
has been there for 40 years.
He's pointing out where Mike Milbury went
into the stands and beat that guy with
his own fucking shoe. Right. The guys
ever seen that. And of course not.
You're not hockey fans actually look,
look up Boston Bruins fight fans.
Just looked that up.
It was a Bruins rangers game and
I think it was Terry O'Reilly.
Somebody grabbed the stick and they
hit him with it thinking, you know,
typical fan like that.
Like that's not a real guy.
He's on skates. I have fucking chuck
Taylor's on. He can't catch me.
I don't know how he did it,
but Terry Riley climbed up the fucking
glass and grab this guy and then the rest
of the Bruins followed him in the stands.
And um,
this is how far we've come as a society.
Back then.
That was probably a story for about five
days. There were lawsuits or whatever,
but you never heard about,
there was no fucking ESPN who's at came
and it went there wasn't suspended for
life, you know? No. Latrell
Sprewell kind of shit. Nothing.
They went up there,
they beat fans with their own clothing
and then they went back on the ice and
they finish the fucking game
as far as I know. Um, anyway,
so then Friday night I,
uh,
I did my first theater Gig and I want to
thank everybody who came out there was
a huge milestone in my career to be
able to perform in a theater in New York
City and, uh, sell the thing
out. Um, everything went awesome.
I got a standing ovation and, um, had, uh,
three killer comics on in front
of me, Joe De Rosa, Paul Versey,
and then there was this
curl if this contest winner.
And of course her name escapes me at this
point because I talk on my cell phone
too much and I can't remember
any fucking thing anymore. Oh,
and speaking of that Shit,
uh, no, no, stay on track.
They'll stay on track because I was
making a couple of corrections from last
week. But, uh,
so Saturday night comes Saturday night
I was up in Boston, I did the, uh,
comics come home with a Camelia,
Denis leary and all that type of shit.
And that was in front of 6,000 people.
So basically over three days I went
on in front of a almost 25,000 people.
And,
uh,
now I'm sitting in my bedroom talking
to myself and do an orange fucking
microphone. So you know, I'm coming down
a little bit, getting back to reality,
you know, how's that for a fucking
weekend? I can't believe it.
Unbelievable. I can't believe it.
And then he says unbelievable.
Just in case she didn't realize
that it was unbelievable right. Now,
you know what's funny about me? I'm
actually self conscious right now that a,
I talked about so much good shit
that happened to me. That's,
that's what it's like to be a fucking
German Irish Catholic from Boston.
That's what it is. Oh my God. A bunch of
good stuff happened. I should feel guilty,
you know? And I almost said fuck you
to you guys. Like you're actually,
you give a shit. Either way. I really
got issues. All right, let's uh,
let's make a couple of corrections. All
right. Last week, that racist movie,
I was trying to remember the name of it's
birth of a nation and I want to thank
the 87 people who brought
that to my attention.
And I also mentioned I was going to
read a book about how to speak better on
stage using, uh, using my voice correctly.
And people want to know the name
of the book that I was reading.
I actually lied to you. I'm not
reading it. I keep starting the book,
but it's really involved.
It's a selector. Dory or fram.
There's emotional when you're deliberate
body. And I'm just like, oh my God,
I hate school.
And then I close it and then I'll read
like slashes autobiography or like,
what's the guy from the red hot
chili peppers? Anthony Kietus.
I'm sort of skipping around his biography.
Um,
but the name of the book is called
freeing the natural voice by Kristin link
ladder.
All right.
L I. N. K. L. A. T. E. R. M. I just
been doing a lot of shows and uh,
I have a tendency to yell from my throat
rather than down here by the fucking
diaphragm. You like that here? That,
that's fucking Ray's famous pizza.
That's an awful burger from a diner.
And that's uh,
some bar pizza that I got up in
Boston trying so hard to get in shape.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
Fuck that pat.
The whole fucking goddamn summer
to get in shape and I didn't do it.
I've been a fucking idiot. Like
usual. I'm waiting till the last week,
like one of these chicks on the
shows right now. I just don't eat.
Then I show up in a strapless
dress with my fucking I fucking,
I was gonna say clavicle showing is that
said though. Was that a word? Collarbone.
There you go. What does the clavicle,
is that that thing on your back?
That looks like a sale.
What does that your shoulder
blade is that call the clavicle?
I don't fucking remember when it radius
Ulna. Tarsal metatarsal Phalanges.
Um, [inaudible] anyways, let's, uh,
let's plow ahead here with the podcast.
So I'm actually now I'm like hardcore.
There's no turning back.
I have to drop like 10
pounds before my special.
All my big fucking TV kitchen,
kitchen,
TV sized head is going to look fucking
ridiculous on TV. So I really got it.
I got to get the booze weight off and
I actually just went for a bike ride.
Um, I was hiking up one of these parks
out here out here at Griffith Park.
You know the observatory. You guys
ever see a, that James Dean movie.
Then he filmed something up
there or Charlie's angels.
And when those four skinny whores are up
there with their botox in their fucking
twats hanging out, remember that last
scene that, that, that's the observatory.
So the other day I was hiking up to it
on foot and I see this fucking like 55
year old guy,
white hair pedaling up the hill.
Like he's in a fucking Viagra commercial
and I'm going to look at that son of a
bitch. You know, when he had
all the, all that he had all,
he had the whole getup on, you know,
the whole Lance Armstrong outfit.
Like he's gonna,
you know,
ride through Paris and throw his hands
up right under the OCTA triumph. Right.
Rather than, he's just riding up
a hill in the middle of a desert,
sucking in bus fucking fumes. But I was
impressed and I was like, you know what,
if that old best it can do it,
you know,
and I got to admit 55 and La is like 32.
The way these people work out
out here. All right. And, uh,
I'm sorry to the people in the middle
of the middle of this country and, uh,
down south. All right. Unless you
love, and people do that when they,
when they insult you and then they say
they're sorry, but you know, they're not,
you know, I get that a lot at the end of
my shows. I didn't think you have funny,
you know, I mean, I'm sorry I
didn't and I'm always like, okay,
yeah, yeah. Cause you know, it's
like, I know other people did,
but you know, it's like, you know,
I'm sorry, I just, I just didn't,
why do you keep a Paul? You're
not sorry. You're not sorry. Okay,
I got it.
You don't like me and I don't give a shit
because you already paid for a ticket.
You paid to watch me annoy you.
And I find that I find that humorous.
Um, anyways, let's plow ahead.
So I figure I gave myself 10 days to be
able to fucking make it all the way up
to this Goddamn Hill.
And I just did it today in the middle,
all the way up to the top.
I'm not gonna lie to Ya.
I feel like I'm going to fucking die.
But I, uh, I actually made it up there.
So now I don't know what to do. I thought
that that was going to be my project.
I would just do that every day.
And every day I get a little bit farther.
And while I would focus on
the carrot in front of me,
I would just drop this booze weight.
Right?
But what happens the first fucking day?
I go all the way up the goddamn thing.
It's now what do I do?
You know what I gotta do?
I gotta join a gym and I
got a Tro to weights around.
That's what I gotta do you know what?
In the mail today,
I got a free 30 days at Gold's gym.
Anybody work at a gym?
How is this free?
30 days going to work out for me.
Sign up for three 34 FRI third
I can't even fucking talk.
The Hell is wrong with me.
I know what's wrong with me.
I've fucking flown like 200 hours on
a plane the last goddamn two months.
You should have seen this fucking douche
bag putting his coat in the overhead
compartment on my flight out here.
I couldn't tell if this guy had the
biggest Yamaka on I'd ever seen in my life
or he had just shrunk his jazz hat.
You know,
you know those little jazz hats
that those black guys were.
And then white guys where when when they
get into jazz to try to act like they
get it to, you know those ones
though, the African colors,
you know,
and you just sit there and
talking about a Charlie Parker,
you know, in your version of salt
peanuts or whatever the fuck it is.
And
I don't know what it was.
Any Jewish people listen to
this shit? Huh? Let me ask you a question.
Is it technically still a Yamaka when
it almost goes to the front of the guy's
guys hairline and all the way to
the two ways. Let me this thing,
it looked like a,
like a,
what is that thing the Mexicans
do they use the, uh, the Tortilla,
right? How fucking ignorant am I
have every goddamn culture out there.
I thought a Yamaka was beanie.
Is that incorrect?
I call him a beanie for a long time and
I always used to get looks. I was like,
yeah, the guy had the fucking, I
had the fucking beanie thing, the a,
and then I get looks and it's like,
oh, this kid's, I cursed. That's I say,
fuck when I'm trying to gather my
thoughts. Sometimes the fucking, uh,
beanie rather than saying the, um, Oh
gee, what is that thing called the beanie?
I put the fucking in front of it
and then it adds an extra edge to it
inadvertently. Then
people like, oh my God,
he doesn't like Jewish people with hats.
Um,
is it a beanie or is a beanie that thing
with the little propeller on top of it?
And another question.
Did anybody ever have those?
Does anybody old enough to actually
answer that fucking question?
Is that one of those Hollywood things,
cartoon things that they just acted like
people used to have those back in the
day, I know kids used to wear
those little raccoon hats.
You know back when it was
game all over the place.
You know mothers made pies and
stuck them on window sills.
Stanley, have you going to
shoot it? You better cook at,
we're going to have to eat it.
Right?
Did white people ever say that or did
we just waste if we always just wasted
shit?
We've always had the MTV
cribs approach to fucking nature
having way white people didn't.
Buffalo bill used to just ride
around shooting buffalo in the head,
laughing his ass off to that Fu Manchu
that connected to his sideburns. You know
what?
How much more did you increase your odds
of having your legs sewed off like soda
sought off what you drank? Brandy, if you
had that little fucking, that Fu Manchu,
what does that one called as far as the
facial hair mask and a lot of questions.
Maybe I should have done some research.
The only person I've seen with that is
that Guy Lemmy from Motorhead and then
afterwards, the dude from Metallica
had it. He had it for a minute there.
James Hetfield.
Why don't we get to the questions here?
I seem to be asking a
lot of questions here.
Why do I get to some of your questions
and I'll try to answer them a question.
A bill.
I have two questions.
I can't help but notice these fucking
annoying commercials and ads about selling
your gold.
Um,
I wondered whether or not you thought
this was a conspiracy to round up all the
gold still owned by individuals so
that when the dollar completely tanks,
the people won't have anything
of worth for themselves. Uh, no,
I don't think it's a conspiracy.
I just think that those guys late night
are doing a much smaller version of the
scam that bankers did originally is what
they're doing is they're taking gold
and they're just giving people
a piece of paper for it.
But it's not as bad as when the banks
did, did the banks did it. They said,
give us your goal,
then we'll give you these little pieces
of paper that are redeemable anytime you
want, you can come back and get
your goals. And needless to say,
eventually, uh, you couldn't
claim your gold anymore. And uh,
they just sort of cap it.
No one knows where it is cause
you can audit them. Um, so yeah,
that's what those guys are doing.
They're anticipating I probably
the tanking of the dollar they get,
I don't know if you guys,
have you seen those commercials
where they're just like,
I used to a bit about it. You
know, if you got an old class ring,
if you got a broken bracelet,
if you got some busted
jewelry sandy and your goal,
then we will give you cash for
it. That's what they're doing. Um,
and for those of you who
think I'm a fucking moron, um,
if you had a sandwich shop and somebody
walked in and tried to buy a sandwich
sandwich with some rubles,
you tell them to go fuck themselves.
But if somebody who came from a country
that used to use rubles but at a handful
of gold, you know, you still would
be like, dude, what the fuck?
I don't know what gold is trading at,
but you'd know that the gold had value.
Okay, that's the great thing about
gold all around the fucking world.
You can get yourself a god damn
sandwich with a piece of gold.
I challenge you to buy anything
with the fucking ruble.
Go ahead and do it. Um,
or some defunct, the yen.
Do they have that anymore in Japan?
Bill, you're getting in over your head.
Shut the fuck up. Just keep moving. So no,
I don't think that that's a conspiracy.
I just think that that's one of the oldest
scams in the book and a JP Morgan and
the guys that was a Jekyll's
island or whatever Federal Reserve,
those guys perfected it.
God bless him. Shame on us.
Fool me once. Shame on you. Fool us
for a fucking hundred years and a yeah,
we're fucking morons. Okay, next one. Um,
also I'll be coming to Cleveland to see
you and wondered if the same guy that
opened for you in Pittsburgh, we'll be
opening for you in Cleveland as well.
Um, oh, that was Doug [inaudible].
Doug Seen Yay. Getting
some props, ducks and yeah,
he's hilarious. I kind of rotate my
openers. Um, when I go to Cleveland,
who's it going to be?
Ryan Dalton in a Jason Lawhead.
Actually two guys that I've known
for about five years right now.
They're based out of Cleveland. Travel
all around. Absolutely fucking hilarious.
And A, I lose half my liver every time
I go out there and work with them.
So I love those guys and they're going to
be opening their fucking hilarious. So,
uh, if you're wondering if I'm going
to have a funny opener. Yes, I am. Um,
next question. Bill. As a say
of bills and a Sabres fan.
I think I have it the worst with two lost
Stanley cups and for lost Super Bowls
and 11 years of 11 years without a playoff
appearance. Do you think I'm right?
No, I don't. I do not. I think you
definitely have it bad. But um,
for the longest time everybody talked
about Boston and then we want a bunch of
shits. So that was over and they have been
talking about the cubs, blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
But I think the worst city to be
a fan in right now is Cleveland.
Very quietly.
Those guys have gone my entire
life and nobody has won anything.
The Cleveland browns have
never won a Superbowl.
The Cleveland Cavaliers have
never won an NBA championship.
And the Cleveland Indians haven't won a
world series since 1948 so and less your
in your seventies.
Um,
for all extensive purposes,
the Indians have never won a world series.
Do you understand that? Cause you gotta
be like at least like eight years old,
nine years old to remember
a fucking world series. Now,
some douche bags going to email me
actually always shakes your job when the
Tigers won it in [inaudible] 68. Who
gives a fuck? You know what I'm saying?
Don't be a cunt. All right. Um,
so I would say that they have it worse.
Um, but yeah, you guys are, you know,
you're right there. You're right there
with them. That's one of those things.
It's like,
do you really want to win that argument?
Remember longtime ESPN long
time ago, ESPN did, who has the,
who had the worst curse,
the Boston red sox or the Chicago cubs
and they did this stupid trial and they
had like George Wendt from cheers, who's
a Chicago guy. He's arguing to be like,
no, we're more miserable. And
it's just like, all right,
you want to win that contest?
That's all you.
Who the fuck would want to win the
misery contest? It's really beyond me.
So congratulations. You didn't win it.
I think people in, uh, Cleveland, um,
our world, I think, how do
you think those guys feel?
Have to fucking guys with world series
rings this year? It used to be, uh,
used to be on the fucking Indians or
half the guys in the world series, right?
Cc Sabathia. Ah, fuck.
Who was the other guy? God dammit,
I had them right at the tip.
I got to stop talking on my cell phone.
Manny Ramirez.
Okay. We'll see how the last couple of
years. Manny Ramirez, red sox bought him,
right CC Sabathia the fucking a Yankees
bought that dude via the brewers.
Who else did Jim tell me play
on the Phillies last year.
I mean, the Indian should have
won it. They should've won it.
But the way baseball is is a, you
know, it's not competitive anymore.
That's why I'm kind of a,
I think I'm tapping out on baseball.
I don't give a shit anymore. Uh, I dunno.
In my world competition, I
was right. Actually wrote an
email to a guy about this.
I met my world. Competition is our
best guys. First. Your best guys,
best team wins. That's
to me is competition. Uh,
I don't think competition is our
best guys. Plus your best guys,
verse whatever the Fuck you
have left. Stupid. You know.
Do you mind when you were kids
and you'd be choosing up sides?
You know when right off the bat,
if two of the best guys were on the
same side or in the end it seemed uneven
people you'll
and when I was from, and it was
called snuck teams Smu, see k,
I've never heard that anywhere else.
I was like,
suck with an eminent snuck people.
Ignore smoke teams.
The teams are smug ain't
what the fuck that that's,
that should have been said like
during the little rascals era,
but some reason it was said during
my childhood, he's a smug teams.
So then you had to break them up.
You had to break up the evil empire,
the fucking, the fucking Yankees
or the red sox Dodgers or whatever.
Any one of these teams. I mean the
Yankees are in a league of their own,
but you know what I'm saying?
Red Sox and all them are just as
much part of the fucking problem.
They would break up any of those kids
know enough to break up those fucking
teams. All right. Anyways, plowing ahead.
Um, let's read, uh, what the
fuck was I going to read here?
Um,
questions already did that,
this is called broads over
there broads over there.
I don't know what the hell it
says. Let's read this one. Bill.
I had been a fan of yours sometime.
Just want to tell you that.
I think you're a great thank you.
Why don't I fucking delete those? Um,
I think your comedy of up at
the [inaudible]. All right.
Anyways, uh, the reason I am writing
you is to tell you a funny story. Uh,
my girl dating five plus years
now and I live in Tucson, Arizona,
and she's always bitching at me saying,
we never do anything anymore.
Well, my job is very consuming of my
time. And I realized that she was correct.
So what do I do?
So what I do is I try to come up with
something we could do together that would
be entertaining and unique,
something different that is not
an average night out in Tucson se.
The guy's using his brain,
trying to surprise her. Anyways,
I've been telling her about your comedy
and showing her clips of you, uh,
that I found on your myspace
page for the past few months.
She really seemed to enjoy
it and laughed hysterically.
So I planned this great evening
for the 20th of November, um,
which goes something like this,
head up to temp Eav,
have a nice dinner and head over
to the Improv and watch your show.
You're eight o'clock show a while I
bought the tickets and thought I would
surprise her with the whole thing.
She loved the idea and she
was very excited and I was
supposed to pleased to see
her excited about the event.
Well,
we were telling our friends about
it and she sort of says this,
well it's his evening and I'm
just throw at a tagging along.
Uh, I got to admit that, um,
I was a little upset at this point because
I intended this whole thing to be a
gift from me to her.
Which is funny because this is very
similar to the story that you told on
October 19 on the October 19th podcasts
when you took your girl in the corvette
up the PCH. She just showed a shot. Ah,
she just showed it sort of shut me down.
Um,
so my question to you is
why is it never enough?
Ah,
what a great question.
Do you realize you just ask the question
of properly every guy on this fucking
podcast, um, hold on.
I'm just going to pause here while the
women roll their eyes and I got it both.
Shit, that's not true.
It's just, you know,
you got to use your imagination.
What did like surprises?
They just fucking
shut up.
Just shut up.
Would you just shut up and take off
all those fucking layers so that the 18
hundreds,
you know with your panties and your
panty hose and your slip and your fucking
skirt. All right. What am I
talking about? I Dunno. Um,
anyways, uh, where'd I lost my
place? I'm, so my question to you is,
why is it never enough?
I can do everything she wants,
but she was still find a way to make
me look like an asshole. Making me a,
making it seem like I'm dragging her
around and making her do all that stuff
that I want to do.
I guess that is why I relate to your
comedy because it seems that she is only
happy when we do all the things
that she wants to do. Uh,
you know what I'm talking you don't want
to talk about with Brunch Street Fairs
in the candle store. Uh, nevertheless,
we are going and really looking
forward to seeing you in person. Uh,
I hope to see you have to show signs
of cds and DVDs. All right. Um,
why is it never enough? I
don't know. I don't know why.
I don't know if it's an
insecurity that they are,
they're always questioning whether
you truly love them or not.
Um, I have no idea. I
don't know why. I mean,
I would think that. All right, look, look,
look at me. Okay. I went, I
rented a corvette for the day,
core veteran vertebral and I
drove my girl all around La.
We went up the fucking Pacific
coast highway, looked at
the ocean, we had lunch.
I took her out to this
beautiful bar late at night.
I drove through the Hollywood hills
with the top down looking at the stars,
looking at the lights out over the city.
I thought it was a very romantic thing
and then I got on the podcast and she was
just like, yeah, that was really
just, that was really your thing.
I just did that for you.
You know,
I just thought of fat there
and a $30,000 automobile,
you know,
seeing views that people fly six
hours to thi and just, you know,
just got a free lunch out of it and free
fucking drinks and you ever watched the
prices right there?
You spit on my own microphone and
you never have the prices right.
You have watched the prices,
right? Sure. We all have. Okay.
Getting a corvette,
I mean like,
and then go into that
restaurant and driving up to
PCH and looking at the lights
and going out to the fucking bar in
the hotel where John Belushi. Oh deed.
Isn't that, that sounds like one in
one of those showcases that you bid on.
Are you going to bid? Are you going to
pass? You know? Oh Dude. You know what?
Speaking of that,
I was watching,
I was watching the prices
right the other day and uh,
I had like a white guilt
moment. Okay, this,
this black dude goes up to go
spin the big fucking wheel, right?
And you know,
you know the deal.
If for those of you who don't live
in this country, you basically,
you spin the wheel,
whoever comes close to dark,
closest to a dollar without going over
gets to then go on and bid on the big
surprises. All right? That's for
people in England and Australia.
And I'll let you to email me
if you don't know the show. So
basically they have every
denomination from 5 cents, 10 cents,
1530 40455050560 all the way up to $1.
So this like 55 year old
black dudes spins the wheel
and it stops on 30 cents.
Okay.
Now you can decide to stay or spin again.
Now I'm not a fucking math
petition, but I think, uh,
you want to hit on 30
cents, right? You want,
he's looking out at the crowd and I'm
like, is this guy fucking kidding me?
And I'm kind of laughing going out.
He's a little bit old.
He's a little bit older,
right?
His family's gonna straighten it up
for him and he looks out in the crowd.
I don't know if they told them, I don't
know what the fuck they told buddy goes,
I'm gonna stay.
He stayed on 30 cents and I'm looking
at drew Carey going like, all right,
I know what Bob Barker would do. Bob
Barker would be like, okay, wait a minute.
You sure you want to stay on this?
30 cents is really low.
He would have helped him through it.
But drew Carey just went like,
he's gonna stay on 30 cents. All
right, let's bring up the next person.
So the dude is standing there
with the 30 cents up above them.
And I wanted to laugh my ass off
and be like, what a stupid fuck.
But then I felt guilty because it was a
black dude and I'd be white laughing at
this black guy. Like he's a
moron. And that's one of the,
that's the worst thing about racist is a
ruined your ability to be able to laugh
at a moron because he's
another color. Then all because all of
a sudden it becomes this ugly thing,
you know, I'll give a fuck what color
you are. If you're playing a game,
we're trying to come close to a
dollar and you stop at 30 cents,
you're a fucking moron.
And I should be able to laugh.
And I was laughing and then I felt bad.
And then I actually thought, oh shit,
someone's gonna take that clip and
they're going to put it up on youtube and
then someone's going to write a bunch
of racist shit underneath it rather than
sticking with the subject
that this individual who
happens to be a black dude is
a fucking moron,
you know?
Or at the very least didn't understand
how the game worked. Look at that.
I had to get, still had to give
him the benefit of the doubt.
A fucking game show that's
been on 40 fucking years. Um,
Jesus Christ. How did I get on that
subject? All right, let's get back here.
So my question is why is it never enough?
You know what?
My girls got the flu right now.
How funny would it be if I actually called
her in here right now with the flu to
ask her this question?
I'm really jeopardizing my relationship.
Should I do what everybody? I think
I'm going to do it. Hang on one second.
Let me see if I can get
her in here. Hold on. Hey
Mia. Hey Dad and your dad.
Alright, she's coming in. Don't
say anything. Right. Watch miss.
Finesse my way through this. Yeah,
it's, come on in for a second. Alright.
Making her way in.
Ladies and gentlemen,
making her triumphant
return to the podcast.
Look at you officially sick,
officially sick pajamas,
socks. Is that orange juice
or you got any booze in there?
On the rocks? Okay. Yes, it is
everything. Don't worry Cleo.
We'll get it. Um, all right.
Here's a question for you.
Here's a question one of my
listeners had. All right. Yeah.
I'm not trying to be hostile here.
This is the female question.
I know we had a big battle about that
dude who punched that chick in the face,
right? Rihanna, Rihanna,
Chris Brown and Chris Brown.
We had a big argument on the plane
about that. It really bad. Um,
all right. Should we talk about that
argument or should we get into this?
Why don't we get into this and then,
and then we'll do the argument,
then we'll wrap it up, then we'll
segue. There you go. All right.
I'll read this to you
and then you have to go.
We have to come closer to the Mike here.
Um, don't look over my shoulder. She,
she reads way faster than me. It makes
me self conscious. All right. Basically,
there's this guy, he's got a
girl. I'm going to paraphrase,
my listeners don't have to
listen to this shit again. Um,
they'd been dating for five years.
She always complains that they never do
anything because the job is very time
consuming. He admits this is job is his
team. His job is very time consuming.
Okay. All right. We're on the same page.
Yeah, we're ready to go. Okay. Listen,
she starts coughing.
Don't make me,
I've been doing this story every
day, all day long. I make a left.
So she starts coughing.
You're terrible. She's like,
I'll
listen to you selling.
He's selling. You worked in a mine.
Listen to that. That's horrible.
God, how did I ever find you attractive?
Oh my God. I'm joking. No, I'm joking.
I told you you're adorable.
All right. So any ways,
any anywhere, easy, easy. She says,
Oh my God, this is horrible.
You sound horrible. Alright,
I'm listening. All right. Stop doing that.
Be a performer here. Okay. All right.
Jerry Lewis would have
just, yeah, sat down.
Um,
anyways lady.
See what a great sense of humor she's
got even with the 105 degrees. So no,
it's not that he doesn't take her,
she said,
she just said he doesn't take her anyway.
Do you understand that? I understand.
Okay.
He has a time consuming job.
She complains that they
don't go a lot of places.
She's claiming that they don't go anywhere
and he admits that he works a lot and
he might not have enough time here.
Okay.
Just don't side with the broad cause she
has a Twat here. All right. Really? Yeah,
I know I had to go there. Makes
the guys laugh. Alright. Uh,
so anyways, so then he just, so he
decides he's going to take her somewhere.
So he sees that I'm going
to be common in town. Right.
He starts showing clips of
me. Um, I, my space page.
Of course she starts laughing cause I'm
fucking hilarious. Right? We know this.
And handsome. Yeah. Thank you. All right.
So he goes, all right, this is perfect.
So he gets tickets to
my eight o'clock show.
He's going to take her out to dinner.
He's going to take her out to the comedy
show. She says, that's not a good idea.
He says, yeah, so we site, he
feels like he's fixed the problem.
So the next night they're talking
about it to their friends and uh,
he says where he's going to go
and what they're going to do.
What should we have done? What
shouldn't we do? Remember that?
No reservoir dogs. Oh yeah. So
you like telling jokes? Huh?
Gig when like a budget girls
in a school yet. I'm sorry.
I know I do. Bad Impressions. Um,
terrible, terrible. I know. So, uh,
anyway, so then he finally ends up
saying it to, uh, he brings it up.
She brings it up in front of
her friends and she said, well,
it's his evening and I'm just
sort of tagging along. All right.
And he goes,
I got omit that.
I was a little upset at that point because
I intended this whole evening thing
to be a gift from me to her.
Okay. Right. So he goes,
it reminded me of when you took your
girl out on the corvette and you said the
same thing. Right? So he says,
my question to you is
why is it never enough?
Yeah.
I don't think that it's okay. I
love it. Your tongue tied. Look at,
see what you're doing right now.
No.
Say what's your exact say
exactly what you're thinking.
Don't do this is you try to figure a way
to spin this shit. Don't spin it. Yeah.
I'm not spinning it because
it's not like it's not enough.
But I think where she's coming from,
it's not like
the whole
he did. No, no, no,
no, no. I, like I said,
it comes from this point of insecurity
that you guys never feel loved enough.
Can you listen to me?
It's hard, but yeah. Okay.
He is a fan of yours first she,
she became a fan of yours but
he is like a long time fan.
So even though she would enjoy
seeing your show, of course it's,
he has more of a connection to you
and your, your comedy than she does.
He has more invested because he's,
he likes you and she had just heard of
you I guess when he introduced her to
your clips on youtube and stuff.
So in a way it's like,
oh well I like it and I'll show it
to her and how she thinks it's funny.
So we'll make a night out of it.
But it's not as if,
I don't know what else she likes.
I mean,
I'm sure she likes going
shopping and whatnot.
So basically the fact that he didn't
see, he didn't say, Hey, you know what,
I have the afternoon free.
You want to like go to the farmer's
market or go like window shopping or
whatever that have been an evening
or an afternoon all about her.
That's like the difference. And
so can I interrupt right now? Yes.
It's a relationship.
There's two people.
It's not a birthday [inaudible] I
understand. If it's her birthday,
it's all about her. She goes,
you never take me anywhere.
So basically the problem here is
the place that he's taking her to,
he can actually have a good time at,
he should actually take her to
something that he doesn't want to do.
No,
I think the issue is that she would have
maybe preferred it if it was 100% all
about her.
Like if it was,
so you guys are selfish
specifically that she wanted to do?
I don't know if she saw for sure not.
Well, it sounds like she's a little,
she's being a little
bratty about it now though.
I'll take that. That was
very, I'll, you know what,
I appreciate that they know what the fact
that you actually admitted at least to
the, now I can listen to your
opinion a lot more open mindedly
yeah, sure. Okay. A little, I mean,
she's being a little bratty to throw
that in there, especially to her friends.
But yeah.
What do you think I would
do? What do, what do,
what do you think I would do
if you did that? If, if you,
if you made the comment in front of your
friends. Okay. And then I've already,
I've, uh, I've already stopped
talking to us. We're coming home.
All we hear is this silent.
We're of our Prius.
See how it starts off. Giulia somehow.
Um, I don't think I was being bratty
though when I made the remark.
No,
I understand it now.
What it was was I loved the
corvette long before I loved you.
So it really was something
more about me then.
Well,
I don't,
was I smiling too much that day?
Is that what bugged you?
No.
Listen,
as awesome as it was to ride in
a corvette down the PCH Malibu,
that was fucking amazing.
It was not the,
one of the things that I had on
my mind as something fun to do.
When you mentioned it, I was like, yeah,
that, that sounds awesome. We did it.
It was even better.
But yeah,
they know we'll, we'll,
we'll wait a minute.
As far as your days that you've had out
here in La, where does that one rank?
It's like number two to my birthday.
See?
Yeah,
a random day in October.
So it was a fucking big time score
and you still had to be like, wow,
that was really kind of your
thing. Why? Why would you do that?
You just said that I wasn't being
bratty when I said it. And now you're,
now you're,
no, no, no, no. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have memory problems. Wait, what?
When did I say what? I wasn't, I sent
you weren't being bratty with what? Okay.
Oh,
I said,
I don't think that I was being bratty
when I said the thing about that.
And you were like, no, no, no. I see
where I see where you're coming from.
You just said it. And that's not what
I meant. Oh Great. How convenient.
Look me,
I can't remember anything from,
I don't have any short term memory
anymore, so I don't know who that guy was.
Who was who. I don't even know if I
was agreeing with you. You know what?
I'm never taking the stand if I ever
kill anybody because I'm not going to be
able to test them on it.
Honesty.
It was a nice thing
that you did and it was,
it was unnecessary for me to say that
it wasn't a, you guys have to hang on a
second while I kiss my sick girlfriend.
Well there you go.
See that wasn't necessarily that guys,
I didn't have to slap her around.
I didn't have to call any of them
names over there like Chris Brown.
Oh I don't.
And it was unnecessary for her to say
that because he was trying to do a nice
thing.
Yes he is more of a fan of you than she
is making it more of an better and more
interesting fun night for him than for
her even though she would have enjoyed it,
but it was unnecessary.
Oh well let me ask you this.
Don't know,
most women just automatically
see that with the idea.
So then would she get self conscious
and feel like she had to call,
call it out before they set it?
Would she may be say that
because she's kind of embarrassed
that, that, that, that like, yeah. Like,
cause if he said it, you know, you know,
what are you doing? Oh, he's taken me.
See this guy, Bill Barry says cunt,
every other word. That's what he's doing
on this romantic night. God Damn it.
I think she might be right.
Yeah. You know what? Yeah, I bet.
What happened was, oh, what did,
what is your boyfriend and doing?
Oh, what are you guys doing? Oh,
we're going to dinner and then we're
going to a comedy show and I don't think
that's necessarily the first thing on a
woman's mind when it comes to a romantic
evening.
Okay. Last question. Tell me,
you didn't feel like you were dating
Paul Newman when we were driving up to
fucking PCH with the top down.
It was pretty impressive.
You didn't feel like Nia
Woodward? I did. It did. Exactly.
It's a fucking great idea.
Ballet like ran up to us and we
pulled into the, uh, parking. Yeah.
Oh, I'm putting in a
special spot. And God,
Pat was back then underneath that
overhang. So the shade would be,
w was be all nice and cool.
Yeah. Was pretty hot. You know,
they don't do that when you pull
up in the Prius, do they? No,
they do not stick that
bitch right out in the sun.
Um, all right. So let's, let's get, let's
get onto, let's get onto our argument. So,
right. We're, we're flying back from New
York City. How amazing was I a town hall?
You were amazing. Standing Ovation.
Yes. Right. You're fucking right.
Am how insecure am I that I had to
make you say that for the sixth time.
You're insecure, but I'm the
yeah, exactly. All right. So
let's plow ahead here. Um,
so we're flying back from, uh, where
are we at Boston at that point.
Yeah. And, uh, I don't,
I don't know if we'd already watched
the youtube clip or whatever.
Rihanna had gone on TV talking to
Diane Sawyer, breaking it down.
Yep. Talking about, um, you know,
getting the shit kicked out of her by
that dude with the beaver teeth. Right.
He really looks like a bug to beaver.
He does.
He has no business being a pop star.
Um,
he better too, right? He did. Why wouldn't
you? You got to utilize your weapons.
So we're sitting there and it's this real
is this really sad interview and she's
just like, I just felt silly and
stupid. You need to do for me.
So this is what I did. So it started
off as a joke and I said, all right,
this is my impression
because wrong.
All right, to go on record as saying
that I feel that this is so wrong,
but the things you do that are so
wrong. All right, well this is the deal.
I was talking about how they, she
was just saying that, you know,
I found an inappropriate text message
and then things escalated and then next
thing you know, he caved in my cheek and
started biting me and Blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. And I was
just like, you know what?
She left out a lot of the details and
cause what I've learned with arguing with
women is when women argue when you're
there or not winning or they're not
getting you to admit that you're wrong,
that some point they make this switch
in there where they're just like,
I'm just going to make this person is mad
as I possibly can by using every ounce
of information that I know about him.
So truth,
uh, you know what? That's
as good as a yes. Anyway,
so this is one of those in the moment
jokes. I can't remember what they said.
I said,
this is my impression of,
of the conversation before.
I can't remember what, how
I did it though. I was like,
wish you see from Barbados,
but for some reason I started doing
this really bad Jamaican accent and I go
Yaman Yaman who be sending you the
text, man, you'll fuck you bitch.
I ain't go say not in your mind.
Who gave you the text message?
You fucking buck tooth be,
I can't remember it somehow talked about
his teeth and you will laugh in your
fucking ass off.
I can never recreate that.
That's why I had to tap out and you will
laugh in your fucking ass off and it
was totally wrong. And, but
then like halfway through it,
I started making my point of how I'm so
sick of every time a woman gets the shit
kicked out of her, not every time,
but all these women they always get,
they always get to show guys in that
bad light of all these guys who beat the
shit out of the women,
but they never show when women fuck
over guys ever in those situations ever.
Like you know the situations that, that,
that, that I've seen where, you know,
a friend of mine,
you know,
she slammed the door into them and then
just called the cops and said that he
hit her and they without question,
arrest him and then that fucked up his
job and now everybody looks at him like
he's a wife beater.
He never even did it.
How come Oprah never does shows about
that? That was our big argument.
And then she somehow, you
know me, the way I say Shit,
somehow it seemed like I was advocating
that the guy did nothing wrong.
And like, just, you know, all women
are these horrible, manipulative yes.
And you're not, you're not horrible
manipulate preachers, but you guys do,
you definitely manipulate.
Can I burn a joke here that,
that fucking milkshake joke, I'll burn
it. I don't have that many, uh, listeners,
I'll still probably do it on my special.
I don't give a fuck.
So here's a little t's kind of
like when you see a movie trailer,
this is kind of a bit I'm
doing on my, uh, my special,
this is what my girlfriend did
one night when I was driving home.
This is how much they manipulate, or as
I call it, lie to get what they want.
I was driving home and I
was looking at this fucking,
there was this diner and I was driving
home and it was late at night. I was like,
you know, hey, you know,
I'm gonna stop there.
I'm going to get one of those milkshakes.
And you'd just like, oh my God.
Fuck you. It's hilarious. Let's
not forget at the end of the day,
my job is to like make those people
left. Okay? Nia, you don't understand.
These people work hard all week.
These were Americans.
They need to come out and forget
about their problems now, whatever.
I don't have one of my Mel Blanc.
I got one fucking voice. I do.
Nice reference. I watch cartoons. Really?
Is that all it takes to
impress you on a first date?
That's how you ended up with me.
He knows who does the voice of bugs bunny.
This guy is a keeper.
I think this guy will be able to provide
what we ever hung out when I hooked up.
We'll save that for another one.
But you gotta you gotta Tell Him, Huh?
You had to be impressed with my skills.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, yes. You'd see
that. They just won't give it up.
This guy was fucking cock
blocking me on an Olympic level.
He saw I was going to hook up. He actually
tried to split a cab with you. Yeah, no,
on the way home and I got around that.
Yeah. Got around that. What happened?
I fucking put the cards. I went all
in just like world series of poker.
I went all fucking in.
She,
she was trying to be all coy with Little
Sammy Davis Jr had on trying to play
all hard to get high thinking you were
dealing with the sophomore in fucking
college. Like I didn't have
any fucking lines. Yeah.
And that douchebag kept coming over,
cock blocking me. He invited we,
we will all set. I was hanging
out. I'm going to tell right now.
We were hanging out.
Right.
Me and this other dude and all of a
sudden he shows up. Right. And I can see,
I can see the vibe. I see the look on
her face. I know she wants it now. I get,
I don't know. He just, you know,
shut up. You look great. You came up,
you had a nice big smile and
you're being flirtatious.
And I immediately liked you.
Right. So you went to the bathroom,
you're with a friend.
I'm with a friend.
Every guy knows what
you're supposed to do.
Take that fucking battleaxe
out of the picture.
Okay. Take one for the team. I can't
remember who the fuck you with.
So if it's one of your friends, I
apologize. Um, whatever. Alright,
a war memorial. Um, so
what is this fucking,
he goes the opposite route. I said, look,
you went to the bathroom. I said, listen,
I'm really doing well with this
girl. All right, so a duty,
I hate to like keep it like a
chick. No, I had to be like,
so if I'm not paying attention, he's, you
don't get upset. This is how like female,
this dude was, right. So I fucked in.
He is where he ends up doing. Okay.
The fucking guy ends up as we're going
to leave, you know, I'm thinking, okay,
he's going to try to peel off with a,
your girl who's not a
battle ax and he just,
he invites another dude over and he goes,
hey,
you guys all want to get something to eat
member and member and invited us over.
Now we're sitting there. It's me. You,
you're not so battleaxe friends and three
other fucking cocks are sitting there
and I'm trying to hit on you. Yeah. And he
keeps jumping in. Then he goes, Hey Nia,
where do you live? Oh, I live up that way.
You want to split a cab? Remember that?
And I had to be like, no, no, no, you
didn't. It was over at that point.
I made the move. Remember that? I said,
are you at least I bought before
he fucking said that shit.
He was doing everything.
I remember I didn't have any cash and
I pulled out my credit card. I said,
you guys just give me the cash or just
put it on my credit card. And he goes, oh,
he's just trying to get the miles.
Remember that anything could do
to make me look like a shithead.
I thought you were like, Bam, I'm paying
for the whole meal. No, no, no, no.
They gave me money cause I didn't
have any cash. This is how I got you,
what you was sitting there.
And I said, look, uh,
we at least going to be able to split a
cab because I wanted to go over and have
a drink with you. And I was like,
oh, we should be able to split a cab.
And then you like, why? Why
do you want to split a cab?
Just putting up the roadblock. And
that's when I went all in. I said,
cause I want to kiss you. Bam.
Right. And then that was it.
I didn't fucking talk to you after that.
Yeah.
You sat there with that little stunned
look on your face. Then what happened?
Then we walked outside them, Dan, Dan,
Dan, we walked out. That was the shit.
That was one of the greatest I used to do.
The fucking guys like that
used to always get me,
I fucking nailed that stuck the
landing like a male Mary Lou Retton
and you know what the best part was.
Then I stood up, we were all, and I,
at that point I was like, fuck
it. I said what I wanted to do,
all this shit is in,
I don't need to talk to her anymore.
And I sort of peeled off.
Right.
And then everybody got up to leave
and then you kind of touched me on the
shoulder, said, don't worry, she
doesn't usually like, don't worry,
we're going to split a cab up
time. And then I'm like, oh,
this is going to be great because now
I'm in and I'm going to get you get to
watch that little fucking cock block,
get his balls knocked on the, on the,
on the fucking sidewalk. And that's
what happened. He came out right,
clapped his hands. Remember that
came out just like you, just like,
so you guys ready to go and you're like,
ah, yeah, actually we're taking a cab.
And he was, and he was so in cock block
mode. He still didn't know. He's like,
oh well they live right near
you. And you were like, listen,
we're taking a cab and we're going uptown.
And you leaned over and you set it.
And then that's when he realized that
everyone realized he was a cock block and
dish. And then what did he do? He goes,
oh yeah. I mean, yeah, oh, hold on.
He just fucking peeled off,
Huh? Then what happened?
My, at my other fucking
classic line, we're fucking
real. June was a masterpiece,
fucking masterpiece. Then we got
in the cab and you said, I thought,
I thought you were going to kiss me.
And we fucking driving like a maniac.
And I go, I can't the calves
jumping around too much.
I go a kiss you at the
first red light right now.
You're trying to make this whole like I
was fucking seducing you and it worked
right? Then we hit the fucking
red light. Yeah, I put one on you,
Bam. Right? Couldn't
feel your fucking feet.
I'm gonna make this story last nine hours
long. And then you know what happened?
Then I sat back and I was playing
mister fucking cool again.
Like I'm fucking Walt Frazier in 1972 oh
the callback to the nicks from an hour
ago, right? Then what happened?
We stopped again and I'm sitting there
looking out the window and you go,
it's another red light right now.
And then,
and then we heard that cheesy saxophone
from every fucking sexy movie in the 80s
right? And then you are going,
I'm not going home with you.
I'm not going home with you. Now,
whenever they say that guys, you know,
they're not going home with you.
You know that shit.
So what you have to do is you have to
constantly make them feel like it's safe
and they're in control.
So before,
actually before you said you weren't
going home with me, I felt your vibe.
I knew the deal. So I just said, listen,
I know we're not going home together,
but I'm really am a good time with you.
I'd like to have another drink with you.
All right. I know a nice
bar. Ba Ba ba ba Bam.
Right?
You didn't go home with me.
We had like fucking eight more drinks and
made out for like the next five hours.
And that fucking hell's kitchen bar
had a great time. Yeah, there you go.
So there's a little story people,
there's your
little backstory hour in one
fucking minutes. There you
go. Oh, you know I've got,
damn it. I didn't get
to this. You want to,
you want to hear something
that's gonna make your, uh,
your fucking privates crawl.
Sorry, what's was disgusting?
I'm out of funny shit. I'm over time
right now. Listen to this guy. You know,
I was talking about that, that cut down
there at the, at the diner that one day.
Remember that guy good. Greg
Did Jersey, you fucking faggot.
Whatever the hell he said.
So people, people were talking
about, people would talking
about like all the, uh,
you know,
all the assholes in the confrontations
and some people had the confrontations.
Yeah, some people won the fights,
some people lost the fight.
Some people want and got sued.
All the people walked away and
had the fucking anger like I did.
So he goes a podcast, the bullies
point of view. This is from the bully.
Listen to this. This is
really interesting, Bill.
I just listened to your last two podcasts
and listen to the stories of these
guys that went, that want to beat
people, uh, when they're bullied. Well,
I think I'm the bully. I've got 100
stories, but I'll give you two short ones,
right?
Fat People Bother me.
This guy's awesome.
Smelly people do to combine the two and
give me lots of alcohol and I go off.
So I'm down the,
uh,
down the hatch and Manhattan and fat
smelly and Fet smelly guys come in,
I can't help but tell them that they are
an embarrassment to the white American
race. This is where he becomes
like this area and psychopath,
I guess this isn't funny anymore.
And he goes,
and I'm tired of picking up their slack
now if he's just saying that to be funny,
that's fucking hilarious for one white
person to say that to another white
person.
You're an embarrassment to the white race
and I'm tired of picking up the slap,
take a fucking walk. At least
he goes, they don't say a word.
So I slapped one right across
the face. He goes, why?
I'm not sure. What's that movie you
love there with, with Christian Bale?
American psych. Yeah. I think this is the
guy I'd love to see his business card.
He goes out, there's six of them.
I have four or five guys with me.
But they wouldn't have known that if they
wouldn't have known that and they just
walked up, they just walked away out the
door probably to grab some fried food.
Uh, but the point is they
didn't do anything. Did I
feel bad about it? Not really.
A, it's a pretty funny story
to tell when I'm drunk.
Most of this story. Oh,
these stories are hilarious.
I don't even know if they're true,
but these are fucking make me laugh.
Arena elements story too.
So I'm at a bar with a couple of
guys and there's a midget in it. Uh,
for some reason I don't
notice the little man,
but my friends do in the
midget jokes commence.
And one of the little men's friends
says something to my friend.
I told him to shut the fuck up
and poured my corona on him. Uh,
he didn't know what to do. About 10
minutes later I ordered a shot and saw
some near the bar and toss that
and him too. He did nothing. Why?
Because 98% of the time, people, uh,
people don't know how to react and clam
up. It's not just your listeners are you,
it's mostly everyone.
So don't feel bad about freezing up
and missing your opportunity. Um,
and you're right that we don't
always get what we deserve.
I've been kicked out of more
bars than I can remember.
I've had sex with more women than I can
remember and showed all of my friends
pictures of them.
Where did it get me
to a six figure salary?
Wait a minute. You just want it to
be fake. You want it to be fake.
Nia, have you ever seen an
asshole who takes what he wants?
Not Bang the hottest fucking
women out there ever.
Thank you. All right, let's
continue. One more thing. Yeah.
So this will make you feel great. All
these, uh, all these guys in your podcast,
he keep talking about picking up girls
or being scared to talk to them or being
rejected, rejected, rejected.
Listen, kids, I love this.
He's talking down to them.
Most of you are in college or
your senior years of high school.
Fucking go out there and crush some pussy.
Have trouble talking to girls. Here's
what you do. Go to your classes.
Come back to your dorm room and take a
nap or play Madden or do whatever till
around 1:00 AM go get a fake id or chalk
your ID and move out to the bar about
one hour before they closed. Scope out the
action in search for blood. Be a shark.
Look for the over inebriated,
the overweight, the low
self esteem. Make it happen.
He's screaming now, make it happen. He's
given a little halftime speech here. Uh,
be blunt. Ask a girl if you
can grab a little titty. Stick
a hand down a chick's pants. When
you're on a dance floor, be aggressive.
All that shit works in the year.
I'm not gonna lie to you putting your
hand out some girl's hands on the dance
floor. You just don't fucking
do what you just saw it.
You start doing other areas
that are gateways to that area.
Lies, lies, lies, yeah. Pain. What if
he turns you on? What if you worked out?
What if he was a dick and he was shredded
and he just knew it was going to be
some great fucking stress relieving cock?
Nia,
uh, uh, you know what?
You're doing right now.
Right now you're being talk show
audience. Nia, let me tell you something.
Anybody puts a hand on my ass.
They getting their ass kicked.
You're full of shit in here. If you,
ah, all right, whatever you're sick.
I'll let you go. Um, and Oh and
never play up the nice guy thing. Uh,
you go in there, look like
you've done this a hundred
times. Scared of performing.
Don't worry, they won't
remember it anyways. And
chances are they've had worse.
All right? So this guy's cocky.
You know, I love about him.
He's cocky for good reasons and
also cocky for no reasons. I mean,
what are his accomplishments? What is,
I know? Well, he's, he slaps fat people.
He makes fun of Friends of midgets.
Any fucks.
A girls who are too drunk to say no,
and now we make six figures.
Come on. You know, we was, she was
trying to be funny, but you know,
he did his thing. You know,
now you've got the attitude.
You don't care if she comes, stays
laser praise. You ever see that?
Remember that guy? Damone
you know, it's funny.
You know what's funny about you?
You already have that look on your face
when you meet a guy who doesn't give a
fuck the same way I didn't.
You got that look on your face.
That fucking look that.
Let me know that someday you are going
to be in my bedroom, which you are.
I just didn't count on me falling for you.
That's where I fucked up.
That's why you turned the tables on me,
Huh? Cutie Pie. All right. That's it.
That's it for the podcast.
You fucking twats you guys.
I got to end on a left and sometimes
we don't have a joke. Go dirty.
I'm teaching these people
how to be a comedian. If I
was on, if they could see me,
I just would have made a funny face.
That's all my act is.
I just curse words and silly faces. All
right, that's a podcast for this week.
I Apologize, um, to you mother
fuckers for a, you know,
tickets so God damn long, but
uh, I hope you enjoy it. And uh,
my next Gig is Tempe Improv in
Tempe, Arizona. I appreciate it.
Anybody who can come out,
please come out to the show cause it's
getting close to my special and tickets
will be going on sale for my special.
I will have information next Monday.
Repeat actually check in on my website
[inaudible] dot com I might have a uh,
a special,
um,
announcement this weekend if you want
to be in on tickets as soon as you can
sign up for my mailing list at [inaudible]
dot com just sign up under the city
that, uh, the, the closest
major city. And um,
I'll send out an email right
before I do the announcement.
That'll be your little plus for getting
on my mailing list. Look at that knee.
A little business skill there. You
like that? Look at me. All right,
let's go have some pork. Chet. What
the fuck are we eating for dinner?
No.
Wow. You don't feel like cooking
anymore. I took you to Sweden in August.
He drove in a corvette and fucking
October, you're not going to cook.
So what the fuck am I supposed to eat?
You're not sick even
laughing your ass off.
You're coming out of it
yet too silly to be sick,
Huh?
Wow.
Pasta. That's what I ate when I was
single and I was fucking struggling.
Really?
Can I eat it on like of the fucking back
of a chair of the way I used to ice.
Put the plate right where
you sit. I already told this
fucking story. All right.
Thank you everybody. Have a
wonderful week. I'll talk to you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].